el presidente Guillermo lasso ha dado
una típico informe a La Nación en este
auditorio del sur de la ciudad de Quito
un informe que en condiciones normales
se habría dado en la asamblea nacional
cerrada tras el decreto de muerte
Cruzada del propio laso previo al
discurso nos habló el canciller Gustavo
manrique sobre toda la situación vivida
en el país
viviendo un
[Aplausos]
proceso presa de la forma masiva y más
democrática insisto esto es un tema que
lo ha aceptado la corte constitucional
que el Consejo Nacional ya ha dado fecha
para la inscripción de candidaturas
Guillermo laso criticó los que según él
son afanes golpistas de la oposición
antes de dar paso a sus logros a los
logros de su gobierno en materia
educativa y de sanidad al final de su
discurso lazo dijo que estas próximas
elecciones anticipadas son una muestra
de que él no se aferra al poder y que
busca dar al pueblo ecuatoriano la
posibilidad de decidir sobre Su futuro a
las urnas no podemos desconocer los
problemas de inseguridad los problemas
económicos la grave crisis política que
generó esta muerte Cruzada sin embargo
creo que el presidente de la república
tiene el derecho de participar y que los
ciudadanos ratifiquen o no su gestión de
Cara a la elección que se dio en el 2021
y nosotros como consejo nacional
electoral estamos desde hoy ya hemos
convocado a elecciones anticipadas para
elegir al nuevo presidente
vicepresidente de la República y
asambleístas el CN trabajando
contrarreloj pero garantizará todos los
derechos de participación política de
los Ecuatorianos y las ecuatorianas y
así mismo garantiza eficiencia técnica y
sobre todo transparencia con este
anuncio del cne tan Solo quedará una
semana de plazo para la campaña
electoral que tendrá lugar entre el 10 y
el 17 de agosto